let's talk about the assassination Qasem
Soleimani was seen as the second most
powerful man in Iran he was killed in
Iraq when the Americans blew up his
convoy using a drone this is the
equivalent of the Iranians assassinating
the US Secretary of Defense Iran is
promising revenge how is Sarah did you
gather a hund'd gear proves high shaft
MEP should we do one apart so who was
major-general Qasem Soleimani why is
there talk of a possible war between
Iran and the US and was the attack even
legal I'm Sandra Gottman welcome to a
special episode of start here you only
have to look at the size of Qasem
Soleimani funeral to appreciate just how
important he was to people in Iran silly
money was the leader of Iran's powerful
Kurds force it's the paramilitary wing
of the Revolutionary Guard Corps and
it's active mostly outside of her own
the u.s. considers the force a terrorist
organization I was here on a thought to
do is create some form of influence in
the region
now they've managed to do that in Yemen
Lebanon in Iraq and Syria and Al Gore's
force has been credited with
establishing that he was credited with
quite enough icism in Iran's focus they
was felt that if he had not made that
dimension then Isis would have taken
over large rate so there are the
administration's of George W Bush and
Barack Obama both considered
assassinating soleimani both rejected
the option as too risky Trump though
pulled the trigger
last Friday sulemani landed in Iraq at
Baghdad Airport he was with an Iraqi
paramilitary commander named Abu Mahdi
al Mohandas and other Iraqi officials
circling somewhere high above them was a
Reaper
a US military remote-controlled killer
drone it's unlikely they would have seen
or heard it to give you an idea of what
these men were facing here's video of a
drone missile being tested
[Applause]
and here's some amateur footage from
Baghdad that reportedly shows the actual
missile strike on the convoy they
probably died instantly did not inform
Congress about these plans to kill
soleimani in advance this is very common
for the Pentagon to present multiple
military options to presidents and times
of crisis the Pentagon did not think
allegedly the Trump was going to select
that option but that is exactly what he
did
so why strike now the Trump
administration says there was an
imminent threat it's the only time an
American president is allowed to order a
military strike on another country
without congressional approval we took
action last night to stop a war we did
not take action just start a war under
US law Trump had 48 hours to explain
himself to Congress in writing and he
did in a classified letter but House
Speaker Nancy Pelosi says it raises more
questions than answers Democrats
basically saying what is the evidence
that you have what is that intelligence
and so far the Trump administration is
not wanting to release that publicly the
assassination of Qasem Soleimani didn't
just come out of nowhere the u.s. and
Iran have been at each other for a while
now starting with Trump's decision and
28 team to pull out of the Iran nuclear
deal that led to the grim possession of
US sanctions designed to [ __ ] Iran's
economy and Iran retaliated by resuming
uranium enrichment and ever since then
there's been trouble in the Gulf region
Iran was blamed for attacks on oil
tankers the Revolutionary Guard shot
down a US surveillance drone then a
Saudi oil refinery the world's biggest
was hit by a drone strike Houthi rebels
in Yemen said they did it but the u.s.
blames Iran at the end of December the
Americans bombed targets in Iraq
Celia killing 25 militia fighters linked
to it wrong that led to people storming
the US Embassy in Baghdad and now the
silly money assassination the fallout
from the assassination has been
immediate the u.s. is urging Americans
to leave Iraq immediately and ascending
extra troops to the region in case of
reprisal attacks women Muslim era when
will I open with it if you really have
you have the roof in her heart toward
Iran and I think it has no limits to its
nuclear activities
now whoever sends the attack there's
been speculation that silly manis death
could lead to war between the u.s. and
Iran but most observers don't expect
Iran will take that chance
you know the Iranian side is very clear
that their conventional military power
is ruled by that of the u.s. Israel and
other regional eyes of the u.s. in the
region but Iran has proven itself to be
incredibly sophisticated at asymmetric
warfare at fiber attacks right after
silly money was killed the Americans
were talking about de-escalating the
situation then Trump tweeted basically
warning Iran to forget about retaliating
because if they did he's already chosen
52 targets one for each American held
during the Iran hostage crisis in 1979
this is talk of Iranian society that did
not detect the presence of the money but
it's not like what Donald Trump has
managed to do with a killing that busts
into the money has managed to unite many
parts of the country in particular
patent president Donald Trump has also
been accused of ordering the
assassination to distract the American
public from his impeachment proceedings
that was bound to happen but whatever
the motivation Donald Trump's decision
to kill sulemani because people around
the world feeling a little
let's see
this story is moving fast and there's a
lot more context I'm history to Iranian
and Iraqi relations with the US to get
into so have a look at aljazeera.com
it's got all the updates and lots of
in-depth analysis as well see you next
week
[Music]